Hier sind Stefan und Florentin, sie sind das fröhliche Toboteam,
stets auf der Suche nach dem Sinn, nur laut dem Zauber der Spaßbeginn,Gem sie schreiben Träume, Geschichten, wunderbunt raffiniert und durchdacht, jedes Wort ein Königswerk. Seid ihr traurig oder einsam?
Hört nur hin wie Sekrezil Worte sanft in Gold verwandt. Stefan, Florentin, Stefan, Florentin und Stefan, Florentin, Stefan, Florentin.
Es ist super Zeit, wir werden hören und lauschen wie beide sanft blauschen. Wow. Wow.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcast UFO. Ich bin sprachlos und Stefan Tietze. Ich bin ebenfalls sprachlos, schön dich kennenzulernen. Und ja, das war das Intro von Tobias. Wahnsinn, vielen, vielen Dank an Tobias. Vielen Dank, Tobias. Das ist wirklich fantastisch. Unfassbares Intro. Man muss sagen, wir haben das schon länger, meine Stimme ist ganz belegt, Vorrührung. Wir haben das Intro schon länger in der Schublade, in der Introschublade und haben ein bisschen auf den richtigen Anlass gewartet, beziehungsweise hatten wir immer so viel Angst davor, diese Folge, dieses Intro zu benutzen, aus Angst, dass die Folge danach dem Intro nicht gerecht werden kann. Das stimmt. Es ist ja oft so, dass deswegen brechen ja viele Serien zum Beispiel unter ihrem guten Intro zusammen. Je besser das Intro, desto schlechter die Serie, ist ja, glaube ich, gängig. Und deswegen muss man da immer so ein bisschen aufpassen. Und ja, ihr könnt ihn finden auf Instagram unter Film and Game Music, wollte ich mal dazu gesagt haben, weil ich glaube, wenn der das macht, dann macht er
bestimmt auch noch viele tolle andere Dinge und
vielen, vielen Dank. Oder er kann halt nur das.
Das kann auch sein. One-Hit-Wonder-Tobias.
Und jetzt hast du so sehr viele Indie-Studios,
die für ihr Spiel irgendwie so einen geilen
Soundtrack brauchen, Hoffnung gemacht,
da kommt nur Grütze raus. Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Mega, unfassbar toll. Ja, dieser Tobias
hatte damals 2018
seinen einen Hit, das eine Intro für die zweihunderte Folge, das Podcast U. Und das hat man ja auch gemerkt, damals ist es irgendwie rumgegangen, das Intro ist viral gegangen, Leute haben darüber gesprochen, über dieses Podcast-Intro und danach kam nichts mehr. Wie erklärt man sich das? Egal, zu welcher Filmproduktion du gegangen bist, es war immer sofort, der erste Name war sofort Tobias, also es war immer sofort zuerst gefallen und man kann es auch nicht mehr haben. Tobias, Tobias, Tobias, Tobias, Tobias. Und danach war es ja auch einer der beliebtesten Namen Deutschlands, auch für Männer und Frauen. Und irgendwann denkt man dann auch, war das vielleicht zu viel Druck dann auch, ist er unter dem Druck zusammengebrochen? Es gab Imitatoren, aber niemand, der ihm das Wasser reichen konnte. Und seitdem ist er verschollen, niemand weiß, was aus ihm ihm geworden ist. Hat er sich umgebracht? Das weiß ich nicht. Wie gesagt, ich lese hier nur diesen Text vor. Ach so. Wie gesagt, sehr undurchsichtige Situation, dass wir beide diesen Text vorlesen, aber auch nicht voneinander wissen. Ich freue mich jedenfalls sehr, dass wir heute hier zusammengekommen sind zu dieser fantastischen Folge von Podcast UFO. Es ist schwierig, es ist so ein bisschen wie wenn man zu Silvester oder so diese Schweinchen Marzipan, diese Marzipanschweinchen bekommt. Und klar, man hat jeden Tag einen Marzipankonsum und so, man verbraucht halt jeden Tag so seine 200 Gramm Marzipan. Aber wann schlachtet man das Marzipanschweinchen? Das Kleeblatt, ja, diese kleine Hummel, die auf dem Schornstein drauf sitzt und so, all diese lustigen. Diese weirden Glückssymbole. Ich finde auch, es gibt zu wenig für Pech und sehr viel zu viel für Glück. Das ist das Schweinchen, dann der Schornsteinfeger mit der Leiter. Der Kobold. Der Kobold. Das ist auch irgendwie so ein Betil. Das frierblätterige Kleeblatt. Das ist immer so, zu Weihnachten hast du halt die coolen Leute, Rudolph the Lord knows Reindeer, ja, Santa Claus, die richtig coolen Leute, die haben die coolen Filme, die coolen Serien. Diese ganzen Silvesterfiguren haben keinen einzigen Film, haben keine Serie, es gibt kein Silvester-Special mit irgendwie Poldi dem Kobold oder so, gar nichts, nichts. Die werden so verschachert, da hat auch keine Firma, hat die irgendwie in Besitz oder so und macht damit Geld, es es einfach nur so, ja, ein Schornsteinfeger. Ich glaube auch, es ist auch so ein Ding, dass sobald man mal in einem Meeting das Wort Silvester droppt, um zum Beispiel einen Film darüber zu machen, gehen automatisch die Gedanken, ah ja, Silvester, ach, was mache ich eigentlich, es geht sofort dieses, ach ja, ist ja bald schon wieder Silvester, was machst du denn Silvester, und dann geht direkt dieses Silvester-Blabla los, wo Menschen sehr anfällig für sind, habe ich das Gefühl. So anfällig, weil Weihnachten ist immer so traditionell, Weihnachten ist immer gleich. Silvester ist oft anders. Und man weiß ja auch nicht warum. Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel jedes Jahr woanders gefeiert, mein Leben lang. Und es ist immer so, man hoppt von Party zu Party, von Jahr zu Jahr. Und da fehlt mir so ein bisschen Tradition, deswegen glaube ich, Menschen sind zu anfällig dafür. Und dann gehen immer diese Gespräche los, ach ja, ist ja bei Silvester, was machst du eigentlich? Und dann entstehen keine Filme. Dieser eine struggelnde Schauspieler, der endlich mal eine Rolle gebucht hat, hat gesagt, ja, ich spiele das Glücksschweinchen, ich habe das Glücksschweinchen, endlich habe ich die Rolle und dann wird jedes Jahr wieder der Film abgesagt, weil einfach ja, das wird nicht produzieren. Ah ja, Silvester. Wobei es gibt gute Silvester-Szenen in Filmen. Ich denke an Boogie Nights. Top 24 Silvester-Szenen. Platz 24, Boogie Nights, als dann die Siebziger vorbei sind, die Achtziger anfangen, fangen, es alles vollends im Chaos da nieder sinkt. Das ist ganz, ganz toll zu sehen und ein wirklich ein toller Break, ein Midpoint, wie er im Buch steht. Platz Nummer 23, Futurama, der Moment, in dem gleichzeitig Silvester ist und Fry eingefroren wird, ein wahrer Hingucker für Jung und Alt. Platz zwei. Hier ging einige Stunden Tonmaterial verloren leider, die wir ersatzlos leider schneiden mussten. Platz zwei der besten Silvester. Das ist nur eine Sat-1-Show, der grosse Sat-1-Counter und so ab Platz 20 haben alle Promis Schwierigkeiten. Platz 22. Silvester ist unterrepräsentiert im Film. Es ist total unterrepräsentiert, genauso wie diese Figuren, die haben nicht mal einen Namen. Dieser Kobold hat nicht mal einen Namen, dieses Schweinchen hat nicht mal einen Namen, Schwanzschäfiger, niemand hat einen Namen und im Grunde interessiert sich auch niemand für die. Und wie gesagt, ich habe wochenlang, monatelang noch dieses Marzipanschweinchen rumliegen, weil du weißt nie, wann ist der Moment und irgendwann ist es zu hart und du wirfst es weg, weil der Bauch ist dick, die Ohren sind dünn und in dem Moment, in dem das Bauchmarzipan richtig durch ist, sind die Ohrenmarzipan ist ja dann wieder zu trocken. Reift Marzipan nach? Ja, ja. Je länger es liegt? Ja, ich glaube, fast alles reift nach. Wissen die Leute, das frage ich mich immer, wissen Hersteller eigentlich genau, was sie da machen?
Wissen Marzipan-Schweinchen-Former eigentlich, dass es niemand essen wird, jemals, dass es in dieser leckerlöcherlichen Plastikverpackung drinbleiben wird, für drei Jahre und dann weggeschmissen wird bei so einer überstürzten Aufräumaktion? Ja, ich frage mich das oft auch auch wenn Leute irgendwie so Essen zu irgendwas mitbringen oder so, oder selbst gebackene Plätzchen schenken. Da denke ich mir auch manchmal so, ist dir bewusst, dass diese Packung ungeöffnet in den Müll wandern wird? Also berechnest du das mit einem Sinne von, ich back die halt so als gutes Zeichen und die werden halt alle weggeworfen, oder ist dir das nicht bewusst? Ich bin da auch gerade beim Umziehen. Ich habe jetzt angefangen, meine alte Wohnung bin ich dabei als auszuräumen und da wohne ich jetzt auch schon sechs Jahre drin, das heißt, da hat sich einiges an Scheiße angesammelt, muss man wirklich mal sagen. Und da machst du eine schöne Kiste oder was, schöne Erinnerungskiste? Ne, eine Kiste, bist du bescheuert eigentlich? Ne, alles weg, aber eine Erinnerungskiste. Ne, ich habe eine Menge Kisten jetzt schon zusammen und ich habe mich von sehr vielen Sachen jetzt schon getrennt auch, aber das ist ja lächerlich, was man da anhäuft für einen Kack und wie viele Sachen ich einfach ungeöffnet der sich schmeiße, wo ich mir mal vorstelle, wie der Stefan von vor drei Jahren, wo dem es ja eine Aufzeichnung in diesem Podcast gibt, wie er zum Beispiel freudig berichtet, wie er was gekauft hat und ich jetzt dem Podcast sagen kann, ich habe es genommen und weggeschmissen. Die Trompete? Trompete habe ich nämlich mit, weil die macht sehr gut als Dekostück, muss man sagen. Aber ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel meinen Lego ATS verkauft. Was? Ja, den kann ich nicht mitnehmen. Wie verkauft? Ich habe den verkauft und zwar für exakt genauso viel, wie ich damals dafür bezahlt habe. Und das Lustige, ich komme auf diese Vorstellung nicht so ganz klar. Weil ich habe damals, habe ich mich sehr geärgert, habe ich auch im Podcast erzählt, ich habe sehr viel Geld dafür bezahlt, weil das sind so Zusammenlaststücke. Und man zahlt sehr viel Geld dafür, stellt die bei sich hin. Jetzt, cut, sechs Jahre später, ich verkaufe den exakt gleichen Preis wieder zurück. Heißt, es ist nichts anderes passiert, als ich habe mir ein Star Wars 80-80 geliehen. Ja, im Grunde. Es ist wie so, ich hätte Geld irgendwo in Kaution hinterlassen, habe den bekommen, hingestellt, nichts damit gemacht, ab und zu Staub gewischt, ab und zu runtergefallen, dann musste ich ihn neu aufbauen. Und dann habe ich ihn jetzt wieder abgegeben und kriege mein Geld, meine Kaution vollständig zurück. Im Grunde schon, ja. Du hattest so ein bisschen Geld in der Jackentasche über den Winter aufgeräumt, dann wieder rausgeholt und ach, da ist ja noch Geld drin. Ich habe nur Besitz verschoben. Pausiert. Ich habe Besitz pausiert. Pausiert, angelegt. Nee, du hast ja nicht angelegt. Naja, das hätte ja auch im Wert steigen können. Aber wie funktioniert das bei Lego? Das sind ja einzelne Lego-Teile. Kann man die sich da nicht schön auf Bricklink zusammenknipsen und dann irgendwie die Teile kaufen und die zusammenbauen? Kann man auch, glaube ich. Was ist denn das Besondere an dem Set? Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Die Verpackung ist natürlich auch ein bisschen was wert und die Originalanleitung, die ich ja noch habe. Die ist, glaube ich, das Gold wert. Habe ich jetzt verkauft, kommen Samstag, jetzt kommen sehr viele Leute von Ebay zu mir. Ebay Kleinanzeigen Leute kommen zu mir und besorgen sich die Dinge, die ich gerade verkaufe. Ich habe bestimmt so fünf, sechs verschiedene Artikel jetzt bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen. Könnten wir reingucken, vielleicht ist da auch was für euch dabei. Ist jedenfalls sehr spannend. Viel Star-Wars-Kram, den ich nicht mehr mit übernehmen kann. Ja, man muss sich aber davon trennen. Die nächste Wohnung, da will ich mal weg von diesem Junggesellen Star-Wars-Deko-Gegenstände. Davon muss man sich jetzt auch mal ein bisschen verabschieden. Dann hau doch gleich die Trompete auch noch mit raus. Ja? Ja. Nee, da habe ich gerade für mich die Grenze gezogen. Ja? Ja, Musikinstrument, da denke ich mir, ist schön zu haben. Da kommt mal ein Trompeter vorbei und dann entbrennt so eine irre Jam-Session, von der man sich noch jahrelang erzählt. Ja, dann heißt es ja, okay, schön und am Ende halten halten sich alle die Ohren zu, weil das das fucking lauteste Instrument der Welt ist. Kannst du doch leise spielen, wenn man es kann, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht auch nicht. Ich habe einmal was bei eBay Kleinanzeigen gekauft, da war ich campen mit Freunden, und wir hatten nicht genug Super Mario Kart DS-Spiele, und dachten uns, fuck, uns fehlt eins, und dann haben wir mal aufay Kleinanzeigen geguckt, so aus Spaß, und es war halt wirklich vierhundert Meter weit, hat halt eine Mutter die alten DS-Spiele ihres Kinds verkauft, und dann bin ich da hin, und das war dann so eine Situation, weil ich weiß nicht, wie das ist bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen, weil man macht ja dann so einen Termin aus, aber man weiß nicht, wie sehr ist das so datig, oder wie sehr intim? Nee, es ist nie datig. Naja, weil ich kam dann da an, an diesem Haus und die Haustür stand offen. Niemand war weit und breit, Haustür stand offen, ich dachte mir so, ah, okay, weil es war das erste und letzte, was ich jemals bei Ebenen hatte. Bin ich im Sequel von S gelandet? Entweder das oder ist es halt so so normal Gang und gäbe, was man bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen halt irgendwie reingeht, ein Streuselkuchen steht auf dem Tisch, man zieht die Schuhe aus natürlich, man guckt sich oben, man streckt sich einmal, man guckt die Wohnung an und dann so, ach ja, schön, gehört Smalltalk dazu, muss man noch eine zweite Tasse Kaffee dazunehmen, also du bist in so einer neuen Welt der Ebay-Kleinanzeigen und kennst dich einfach nicht gut aus. Und dann ist es halt schon so, das Risiko, jetzt was falsch zu machen, ist, also die Konsequenz von was falsch zu machen, ist so viel schlimmer, in eine Fremde zu Hause zu gehen, wo man nicht eingeladen ist. Ich liebe mich gerade, ich bin ja an der Stelle der Verkäufer und als Verkäufer bist du der, der dir die Regeln aufstellt. Und du bist auch der mit der Macht. Und gestern habe ich so gemerkt, warum gefällt mir das so gut, Dinge zu verkaufen? Weil ich Geld bekomme? Weiß ich nicht. Das Geld habe ich auch mal ausgegeben, ich mache ja keinen Gewinn. Ich kriege ja nur meine Kaution zurück. Das ist ja basically. So, ist es das und ist es mal auf einmal Nein. Der Grund, warum ich so liebe, ist die Machtposition, in der man plötzlich ist. Dieses, ja, du kannst morgen gerne vorbeikommen, mir passt es nur morgen zwischen 17 Uhr und 17.03.
Kannst du dann die Gitarre bei mir abholen und die kaufen? Und dann sagt er, nee, da kann ich nicht, ich kann nur übermorgen, kannst du da auch? Da sag ich, ja, dann wollen wir aber hoffen, dass die Gitarre bis dato nicht an jemand anderen verkauft wurde, der vielleicht mehr bietet. Oder nein, nein, kannst du die nicht reservieren, nein, kann ich nicht, nein.
Ich höre nur so ein Fisteln, die Peasants rufen zu mir hoch. Ich höre dich gerade nicht im Chat. Oh, die Verbindung ist schlecht. Kann ich gerade nicht lesen. Ich habe gerade ein Glas Wasser auf meinen Bildschirm geschüttet. Hups, huch, mein Akku geht gleich aus. Ja, man fühlt sich so mächtig in dieser Verkäuferposition, weil die wollen ja was von einem. Was natürlich nicht stimmt, aber als der Verkäufer kommen sie ja zu einem, man ist ja der mit der offenen Tür und den Rätseln auf dem Fussboden, wo man in welchem Zimmer der ETS steht. Der Schlüssel ist, ja. Ja, und dann immer die Frage bei Lego-Sets natürlich, verkauft man die jetzt zusammen oder auseinandergenommen?
Ach so.
Und stellt sich heraus, auseinandergenommen. Und dann saß ich da wirklich jetzt gestern, den halben Tag, und habe den Lego ATS-T auseinandergebaut. Und man kommt sich bescheuert vor, man hat den ja auch aufgebaut. Ja. Selten im Leben baut man was auf, als Sammelgegenstand, stellt es irgendwo hin und baut es dann wieder ab, um es zu verkaufen. Das war wirklich seltsam. Das war ein ganz komisches Gefühl. Und vor allem, manchmal ist man dann so, das ist dann, weil man übersieht was, weil man geht es dann so in Routine über. Also erst macht man es mal sehr bewusst und irgendwann guckt man so nebenbei dann doch eher Gilmore Girls als als ATS, die Lego auseinander bauen und dann bleiben halt manchmal Teile zusammen, wo ich mir denke, dauert das jetzt länger für den, will er sich ärgern, oh, es ist schon zusammengebaut bei manchen Teilen. Unmöglich war ich so aufmerksam, dass alle Teile jetzt auseinander sind, da sind mit Sicherheit drei, vier Teile, da hängt noch ein anderes Teil mit dran, bin ich ganz ehrlich. So, Betrug bin mir nicht sicher, wo Betrug anfängt oder Faulheit anfängt. Und wird er sich dann sauer sein oder wird er es nie zusammenbauen können, weil die ganze Zeit dieses Teil sucht und es ja unmöglich finden kann, weil es an einem anderen Teil dranhängt. Ja, das ist wie wenn du so ein gebrauchtes Puzzle kaufst oder so und dann sind schon drei Teile zusammen und du sagst, nee, das ist jetzt Spaßverlust. Geh mich zurück. Ich habe jetzt unter dem Strich weniger Spaß. Weniger Spaß. Weniger Puzzle-Freude. Oder hat man nicht mehr, aber sie haben doch mehr Spaß, weil das Erfolgserlebnis macht ja Spaß. Und wenn sie einen Teil finden, was schon an zwei anderen Teilen richtig dranhängt, haben sie doch mehr Spaß, weil das Erfolgserlebnis größer ist. Aber ich will doch selber puzzeln, ich bin doch hier, um zu puzzeln. Ich will doch alles zusammenpuzzeln. Also wollen sie jetzt zurückgeben, oder was? Ja, ich will es zurückgeben, da waren drei Teile schon ineinander gesteckt.
Und auf der Box ist ja das Bild drauf.
Da weiss ich ja schon, was draufkommt.
Also wollen Sie nicht wissen, was rauskommt?
Nein, ich will doch zusammenknibbeln, puzzeln.
Aber, okay.
Das ist ja auch alles in der Box drin, da sind ja alle Teile zusammen.
Ich will doch die Teile suchen.
Ich will doch erst mal gucken, wo ist die Eck, wo ist das Teil? Wo wird es sein, in der Kiste drin. Das habe ich mir ganz anders vorgestellt. Okay, dann würde ich es jetzt zurücknehmen, ist kein Problem. Aber kurze Frage, bei Büchern, lesen die dann den Klappentext vorher? Nein, nein, nein, was? Ob sie den Klappentext lesen, hinten auf Büchern drauf? Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber sie müssen doch wissen, worum es geht, was sie lesen. Nein, ich will doch erst herausfinden, worum es geht. Wo arbeiten sie? Ich lese ein Buch und dann heißt es, oh, dann gehen die in den Schrank rein. Wohin kommen sie? Nach Alaska, in der Blumenwelt, unter Wasserwelt? Nee, Narnia. Und hätte ich den Titel angelesen, hätte ich das schon gewusst. Ja, aber das verrät ja nichts über den Inhalt. Narnia? Weiß ich doch, wo es ist. Okay. Also wie gesagt, ich bin wirklich masslos enttäuscht und ich gebe das zurück. Und wenn ich ihn das Puzzle auseinanderbaue komplett und in eine diskrete Kiste packe, wo nichts draufsteht.
Nein, doch nicht in der Kiste, es macht doch Spaß, sie zu suchen.
Das sind die Teile.
Ja.
Soll ich die Teile in der Stadt verteilen?
Ja, jetzt haben sie Stadt gesagt.
Jetzt weiß ich, wo es ist.
Ich nehme die Dominosteile.
Okay, es macht dann 17 Mark.
Nein, nein, nein.
Oh, nicht sagen.
Ja, das ist wirklich die Frage, wo hört dann der Spaß auf?
Ja.
Finde ich schwierig. Naja, ich freue mich schon.
Es ist schwierig. Also wie gesagt, falls ihr jemanden, der bei euch einkauft und falls auch du jemanden bei ebay Kleinanzeigen massiv verwirren möchtest, wie gesagt, lass die Tür offen.
Das war für mich so eine unüberwindbare Hürde, wo ich mich auch danach und dann stehst du halt vor der... Bist du ein Vampir? Musst du eingeladen werden, bevor du ein Haus betrittst? Naja, ich weiss gar nicht. Wieso ist es eine unüberwindbare Hürde? Bist du ein Vampir? Das ist schon ein Verdacht, den ich auch nicht länger muss. Ich muss ehrlich sagen... Was heißt, bin ich Vampir? Ich bin schon länger. Neulich habe ich mich einmal einmal geschnitten vor einer Live-Show, dann habe ich ein bisschen geblutet und du hast so draufgeschielt die ganze Zeit. Du warst auch so ganz nervös und so schwitzig. Jetzt schon wieder, allein wenn ich das Wort Blut in den Bund nehme. Nein, ich weiß ja nicht, wie das ist mit den Vampirregeln, ob eine Ebay-Kleinanzeigen-Einladung auch zählt. Kommen Sie zu mir, klingeln Sie einfach. Ja, klingeln Sie einfach, aber nicht kommen Sie rein. Das ist technisch gesehen eine Einladung zum Klingeln, nicht zum Betrieb des Hauses. Müssen eigentlich dafür alle Vampire Jura studiert haben, oder wissen die das so? Na, es sind Details, weil was ist genau eine Einladung? Kommen Sie rüber, kommen rüber, so ist ja die Frage. Kommen Sie rüber. Ja, das ist noch gesieds, das ist zu höflich, da ist noch Abstand mit drin. Aber es ist ein Kommen Sie, es ist auch kein Kommen Sie bitte rüber. Komm mal her. Komm mal. Also was ist das? Also kann ich reinkommen jetzt. Nee, komm mal her. Ja, sag ich doch, komm her. Das ist schwierig. Vor allem, dann hast du halt diese offene Tür und dann ist die Frage, kann man noch klingeln? Oder ist es dann eher dieser Heo, Heiss, Heia, Heissa. Hossa, Hossa. Diese Heda, Heda, sowas, wo in Schiller-Theaterstücken immer drinsteht und wo sich alle Schüler gleichzeitig die Augenbrauen zusammenziehen, wenn da steht Heda, Heia, Franz Mohr. Man kann doch immer so zum Regisseur slash Erdkundelehrerin gucken und sagen, können wir nicht einfach Hallo sagen? Nein, wir sagen Heder. Wo man auch im Französischen dann so Hain oder so und man übersetzt es in irgendein anderes Wort, weil es halt so was heißt wie so ein Begriff und man übersetzt es mit Hain, als wäre das Name, irgendwie Hain und dann hat man viel zu viele Personen in der Geschichte. Warum wird dieser Hain nie wieder angesprochen? Ganz, ganz furchtbar. Ganz furchtbar. Aber ich habe mich dann entschieden zu klingeln und das ist ja das Unangenehmste, was es gibt, zu klingeln, um dann die Person, die im Haus wohnt, noch den Hausflur dir entgegenzulaufen. Und dann hast du diese unangenehme Situation, dieses ab wann sagt man hallo, wer sagt hallo. Man sieht ja auch dann die weirden Gesten, dieses auf die Uhr gucken, dieses, oh, viel zu früh. Und dann sieht man ja dann alles. Diese typischen Sachen, die man macht, wenn man zur Tür geht. Also furchtbar. Aber am Ende hat alles gut funktioniert, aber das war mein erster und letzter Zusammenschluss mit Iber Kleiner. Ich habe jetzt so etwas verkauft, eine erste Sache, und dann kam ein älterer Herr hinein, hätte ich auch nicht erwartet, beim Namen schon nicht, das war irgendwie so ein jüngerer Name, so Dennis-artig, und dann kam ein sehr alter Mann schon davor, habe ich so nichts zusammengebracht, es kommen immer andere Leute, das ist auch die erste eBay-Kleinzeigen-Regel, es ist nie derjenige, den du erwartest. Männernamen sind immer Frauen, Frauennamen immer Männer, Jungennamen immer ältere,
kannst du nie sagen,
du brauchst gar nicht die Gedanken vorher machen.
So, und dann kam dieser alte Mann namens Ulrike, kam rein und hat dann das bezahlt. Und zwar mit einem 200-Euro-Schein und einem Zwanziger. So, und das, ich habe in meinem Leben noch keinen 200-Euro-Schein gesehen. Er war gelb, so quietschegelb. Ja. Und jetzt dachte ich mir, ja, der ist doch gefälscht. Wenn ich Fälscher wäre, würde ich natürlich auch über Ebay-Kleinanzeigen Dinge kaufen. Warum kauft man dann sowas? Ja, aber dann musst du dein gesamtes Geld irgendwie in eine alte, lustige Taschenbuchkollollektion investieren und am Ende denkst du dir, warum haben wir Geld gedruckt, wenn wir am Ende irgendwie einen alten Toaster irgendwie Mickey Mouse-Magazin und Besen. Wir hätten lustige Taschenbücher fälschen können. Stimmt eigentlich. Warum fälschen wir nicht das, was wir von dem Geld kaufen wollen? Scheiße, stimmt. Warum fälschen wir nicht einen Sportwagen? Wir holen uns so billiges Plastik und formen das wieder in einen Sportwagen. Nee, das machen wir irgendwie. Nee, wir machen das Mittel, was man braucht, um den zu bekommen.
Das fälschen wir.
Ja, die Briefmarken fälschen wir.
Haben wir gerade entdeckt, das fälschen wir.
Ja, die Briefmarken fälschen wir. Haben wir gerade entdeckt, dass Fälscher keinen Sinn ergeben? Ja, wie gesagt, don't fälsch the middle man. Aber dann dachte ich mir, und jetzt bin ich ja kein Experte für Geldscheine und Fälschungen, jetzt weiss man ja diese Sicherheitsmerkmale auf diesen Scheinen, dass man diese 200 unten gegen das Licht hält und dann mit der Rückseite ergibt es dann die 200. Hast du denn wirklich vor dem Kunden die Sicherheit? Ja, ja doch, und zwar genau, war mir dann auch unangenehm, deswegen habe ich es verkauft als, wow, ich hätte noch nie einen Zweihundeter. So sieht also der Zweihundeter aus. Das ist ja spannend, Halte dich mal gegen das Licht, so habe ich ihn noch nie gesehen. Ich habe es die ganze Zeit so verpackt. Aber auch dabei hat er also auch reagiert, so wie jemand Fälscher reagieren würde. Er hat nämlich gesagt, die ganze Zeit, ja, und wundern Sie sich nicht, wenn der Automat den nicht annimmt, wenn Sie den einzahlen. Und dann habe ich so angeguckt und habe gesagt, ja, nee, warum nicht? Warum soll ich mich nicht wundern? Das ist doch schon echte Scheine werden doch angenommen, oder? Die Vorstellung, dass man sich einen KitKat für 1,20 Euro am Bahnhof kauft und mit einem 200-Euro-Schein zahlt und einfach mal einen Jackpot hat und einfach 1000 angenommen hat. Es war wirklich, und dann dachte ich mir, aber er war gelb auf der anderen Seite, wo ich dann dachte, ja gelb, die Farbe der Treue. Es macht schon Sinn, die ist über noch, dachte ich. Weil hunderte hat man schon mal gesehen, hunderte sind grün, so kriegt man mal mit so Weihnachten geschenkt oder so. Ommers haben hunderte und Opas. Dann alle anderen Farben sind auch weitestgehend belegt, gelb ist noch über. Für mich jetzt Perfectly Sense, ich habe den noch nicht mal im Internet gesehen und da habe ich den danach gegoogelt und er sah auch so ähnlich aus, hatte sich aber auch falsch angefühlt und er meinte auch, ja, das ist der alte 200er. Wieder so einen Satz. Das ist schon wieder so ein Satz, wie dieses Fälscher-Ding von gerade, oder dieses Automaten, nimm den nicht an. Wir sind beim Fälscher-Bingo kurz vor Gewinn. Ich war kurz vor Bingo und hätte fast mein lächerliches Ebay-Kleinanzeigenprodukt wieder genommen. Wenn er jetzt noch sagt, geben Sie ihn erst nächste Woche aus, dann haben wir einen Gewinner. Und sagen Sie niemals meinen echten Namen. Deswegen dachte ich auch, dann hat der Film diese Namenssache wieder ein, die nicht zu ihm passt. Und ich dachte, ja okay, vielleicht ist das auch ein falscher Name, den er angegeben hat. Wenn er sich umd rufen und gucken, ob er reagiert. Ja, er hat sich nie umgedreht. Was? Er hat sich nicht umgedreht, ist gegangen. Hat gesagt, so weiss ich gar nicht. Ach doch. So, und dann habe ich das Geld genommen, was ich durch meine vielen eBay-Kleinanzeigenverkäufe eingenommen habe, und bin damit zur Bank gegangen und habe diesen Packen in den Automaten gelegt. Es gibt manche Automaten, da kannst du auch Geld einzahlen. Dann geht die Klappe auf, machst rein. So, und dann war das so ein, dann geht das Geräusch los, diese Trommel, das drrrrrr. Und dann hat man kurz so einen Zögern des Automatens gehört. Das war so ein drrrr. Kurzes drrrr, drrrr, drrrr, drrrr, drrrr. Dann ging es wieder los und dann ging diese Klapplappe auf und auf dem Display stand, bitte entfernen Sie die falschen Scheine oder so. Und drinnen lag nur noch der Zweihunderte. Okay. Ja, dann habe ich den genommen und dachte mir, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein, denn es hat mich jetzt echt verarscht oder was. Und dann bin ich zum Schalter gegangen und da konnte ich ihn einfach einzahlen. Und es war nur ein alter Schein und so hohe, große Scheine können nicht angenommen werden vom Autobahn. Aber es war ein richtiger Schein.
Aber was ja auch mal, in Supermärkten werden die ja auch manchmal getestet und dann gibt es immer diesen Stift, dass sie mit diesem Stift drauf malen, was ich unglaublich finde, weil, also was ist das und wie geht der dann auch wieder weg? Vor allem, ja, ich frage mich mal, wurde der Stift mit dem Stein entwickelt? Also hat die Zentralbank sich gedacht, wir machen das aus einem Material, die eine bestimmte Chemikalie erkennt? Ja. Oder hat, nachdem der Schein gedrückt wurde, ein Stifthersteller gesagt, ah, okay, wir haben folgende Chemikalie entdeckt, die reagiert so und so auf echtes Geld oder falsches Geld. Vor allem, kann man diese Stifte denn kaufen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber damit Fälscher müssen das, also die nehmen, die hilft ja
den Fälschern dann, wenn du diesen Stift hast.
Ich könnte auch einkaufen.
Dann kannst du das ja so reverse-engineeren, dass es nicht anspringt oder doch anspringt.
Das müsste man herausfinden.
Springt es denn an bei Falschen oder springt es nicht an bei...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also so bei echten Scheinen streichen sie drüber und es passiert nichts, Bei falschen Scheinen streichen sie drüber und es macht rapapapam! Dann merken sie, dass es eine Fälschung ist. Ich glaube auch 80% von Kassierern, die das machen, Kassierinnen, wissen nicht genau, was passieren sollte, wenn es denn falsch wäre. Und was soll ich da draufschreiben? Wissen Sie was? Was sie möchten. Wir schreiben, was Sie wollen. Schreiben Sie einen Namen, schreiben Sie Herzchen drauf, schreiben Sie Mario Draghi drauf, was Sie möchten. Kann ich auch eine Zahl drauf schreiben, eine andere Zahl? Oder ist das ein Fälscher? Nee, das ist, nee, nee, das finde ich nicht gut. Tatsächlich habe ich lange überlegt, ob ich nicht Kassierer werden soll.
Ja, ich auch. Ich habe einen tollen Job finden, aber tatsächlich habe ich mir gedacht, nee, weil ich finde, ein Element des Kassierens finde ich stressig. Kundenkontakt. Und Waren. Und Geld anfassen. Dieses Piepding finde ich cool. Ja, ich auch. Aber vor allem, du musst ja Geldscheine, die du bekommst.
Du hast ja drei verschiedene Inputs. Geldscheine, Geldmünzen und Pfandscheine. Und Paybackkarten. Ja, okay. Aber das ist nicht wirklich ein Input. Aber Geldscheine musst du ja in die Kasse legen. Bonscheine musst du zerreissen. Und ich dachte mir, am ersten Tag... Du zerreisst die Scheine und legst die Bons in die Kasse. Was haben sie hier getan? Wirklich komplettes Chaos, einfach macht dann 54 Euro, zack und sie in Geldscheinen zerreisse ich und spiesse ihn auf diesem Schafott auf, auf diesem Pfahl, der noch aus der Römerzeit üblich gebt. Wo diese toten Bons hängen, die alle rufen, töte mich, Gunn. Sei es eine Warnung für alle Bons, die in dieses Land reisen, so endet ihr hier, zack. Und natürlich würde ich dem hier auch... Oh, das ist so befriedigend. Ich dachte immer, ich will immer jedem Kassierer zurufen, seid vorsichtig, seid bloß vorsichtig. Vor allem, ich hätte glaube so ein spitzes Ding. Ich will ja mit dem ersten Tag da sitzen, erster Tag Kassierer mit dem, und die Hand drauf, oh bitte gib mir einen Bon, bitte gib mir einen Bon, ich will es aufschliessen. Und irgendwann bin ich so ungeduldig, dass ich einen Schein kriege und einfach reflexhaft und meine gesamte Hand bohre einfach, zack, es wirkt wie dieser Zaubertrick, wo ein Nagel unter drei Bicher ist. Genau, das was du gerade gesagt hast. Ja, und, und dann einfach zack, ja, Kassira ist so toll, weil du hast so deine kleinen Arbeitsplätzchen, du hast deine Arbeitsplätzchen, du kriegst mal viel Besuch von deinem Arbeitsplätzchen und du hast nicht so viele Aufgaben, das ist ein sehr beschaubarer Beruf. Ganz kurz, es gibt ja, ganz kurz, gib mir mal, gib mir mal so zwei, drei Berufe, denen du schon mal ein Kompliment gemacht hast, dass sie eine gute Arbeit machen. Nenn mir mal zwei, drei Berufe. Kommt auch als Brettspiel raus für einen Nerdjob, keine Angst. denen ich schon mal ein Kompliment gemacht habe, weil sie ihren Job wirklich gut machen. Ja. Es kommt nicht so häufig vor, weil man ja auch immer von den Leuten den Beruf ausübt, erwartet, dass sie den Job gut machen, sonst fragt man sich mehr, warum machen sie den Job denn dann? Kassira tatsächlich war noch nie dabei. Schwierig. Aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, es gibt manchen da, also natürlich so in so einem kreativen Umfeld, man hat schon, okay, das war einfach gut, irgendwie hast du gut gemacht. Also ich habe ja das Gefühl, dass Komplimente eher nach unten gereicht werden, nicht nach oben, dass man nicht seinem Vorgesetzten sagt, hey, ich finde, das ist eine gute Arbeit geleistet, sondern eher seinen Untergegenen. Kommen Sie mal kurz her, kommen Sie mal kurz her zum Chef so. Ne, komm, lass Sie sich mal kurz her. Meine Sache. Also was Sie eigentlich haben. Ich wollte Ihnen mal was sagen, machen Sie das richtig gut, machen Sie das. Wirklich? Grüßen Sie immer Ihre Frau. Wirklich? Ich war mir nicht sicher, weil Sie immer so nervt gucken, wenn ich die Quartei in die Quarteihe. Ne, kommen Sie mal her, lassen Sie sich mal drücken. Ich bin doch schon recht nah dran. Lassen Sie sich mal drücken. Na gut, okay, wenn es sein muss. Ich wollte Ihnen mal sagen, Sie sind ein richtig guter Chef. Nein, nein, Herr Kleber, Sie sind ein guter Chef. Dankeschön. Das sagen ja alle. Ja, danke schön. Finde ich nett. Jetzt können Sie wieder gehen. Okay. Können Sie die Tür, die sich schließen würde. Tür. Weil, also ich glaube, man macht eher Leuten Komplimente, mit denen man eng zusammenarbeitet, aber irgendwie auch nicht. Keine Ahnung. Letztens habe ich mir gedacht, weil ich habe die beste Kassiererin der Welt gefunden.
Und
die macht, die ist perfekt,
wirklich, die arbeitet schnell
und die hat die perfekte Technik
entwickelt und da merkt man, dass jemand Leidenschaft,
Leidenschaft ist zu viel, aber dass jemand
zumindest Interesse oder Aufmerksamkeit
seinem Job gegenüber macht, weil die hat
die klassischen Probleme des Kassierertums
gelöst.
Also du hast ja so Sachen, die du immer und immer wieder
Vielen Dank. Interesse oder Aufmerksamkeit seinem Job gegenüber macht, weil die hat die klassischen Probleme des Kassierertums gelöst.
Also du hast ja so Sachen, die du immer und immer wieder machst und merkst, das ist ein Problem.
So dieses klassische, lege ich das Geld dem Kunden in die Hand oder lege ich es irgendwo hin und das ist manchmal, funktioniert es nicht ganz und das sind ja so Problemchen, die mir da aufkommen. Und ich glaube, den meisten ist es einfach egal, so, weil ich glaube, viele Kassierer sind jetzt auch nicht mega leidenschaftlich dabei. Warte. Auf jeden Fall habe ich diese Kassierer gefunden, die hat, weil das große Problem, ich kann da ins Detail gehen, weil ich habe mich damit beschäftigt. Das Problem ist ja, wie gesagt, wir haben ja gesagt Input, es gibt drei Inputs und es gibt zwei Outputs, weil die Bonds werden, wie gesagt, hingerichtet zur Belustigung des Volkes.
Wohingegen als Output ...
So kleine Galgen wäre auch schön.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Oder so verbrannt.
So ein kleiner Scheiterhaufen.
Ist ja auch immer brutaler.
In so zehn Jahren verbrennt man die so von den Augen des Kunden.
So aufgerollt und so eine kleine Guillotine geschickt.
Ja.
Zack!
Und Output ist immer Scheine und Münzen.
Aber das Problem ist, in welcher Reihenfolge?
Viele geben die Münze ... Auf den Schein. Auf den Schein. Und die Rutsche, die klassische Rutsche. Du kennst die Rutsche? Die Rutsche ist ein beliebtes Mittel. Wirklich? Ja. Weil sie macht die Rutsche. Die Rutsche ist ein beliebtes Mittel. Und die Rutsche habe ich noch nirgendwo erlebt. Nein, das ist nicht gängig. Das stimmt. Nein, das ist nicht gängig. Nein, da gehst du in die falschen Reves, Edekas, Ligels und all dies dieser Welt. Nein, wirklich. Erklär die Rutsche. Die Rutsche, in meiner Erfahrung nach, und ein beliebtes Mittel, entzaubert mir immer ein kleines Lächeln, weil es auch spaßig aussieht, ist Münzen auf Scheine, Schein wird leicht gerollt, leicht gerollt, Hand wird ausgestreckt in die Kundenhand, und die spaßigen, belustigten, rutschenden Münzen landen an der Hand. Und dann kannst du dir mit den, nimmst du quasi kleiner, den kleinen bis Mittelfinger, um die Münzen festzuhalten und kannst dir dann mit Daumen und Zeigefinger die Bargeld nehmen und gehen. Weil es ist perfekt, weil Kleingeld gehört in die Handfläche, die Scheine gehören in die Fingerspitzen. Und wenn du einfach, viele Kassierer geben auch einfach den Geldschein und das Geld obendrauf und dann ist es falschrum, weil dann hast du den Geldschein unten auf der Handfläche und die Münzen oben drauf und das ist falschrum. Und deswegen, die Rutsche ist perfekt. Und sie macht die Rutsche, und ich kenne keinen anderen, der die Rutsche macht. Und sie macht die Rutsche perfekt und es ist jedes Mal großartig. Rutsche habe ich aber schon oft gesehen, dass gerade bei älteren Leuten die Rutsche zu Verwirrung führt. Die nehmen dann die Scheine, dann fällt das Geld hin. Oder bei falschen, überhastigen Kassierern wird die Rutsche zu schnell, zu steil ausgeführt. Ja, das ist ein Fehler. Und dann rutscht das Gang in, nein, so eine Lichtgeschwindigkeit, rast es auf den Kunden zu, da muss man aufpassen. Aber die Rutsche ist ein gutes Mittel. Die Rutsche braucht ungefähr dieselbe Geschwindigkeit wie tatsächliche Spielplatzrutschen, immer langsamer, als man denkt. Ja, ja. Auch als Kind, man sieht die Rutsche und denkt, boah, Alter, das ist ja, wie konnte das jemals jemals überleben. Halsbrecherisch, ja. Und dann sitzt du drauf irgendwie und dann rutscht du halt einfach gar nicht und musst so diesen Vor- und Zurück-Rüttler machen. Und denkst du, wow, es ist auch erst zwölf Uhr, denkt man dann. Ja, können wir wieder gehen. Wie kriegen wir den Tag jetzt rum? Ich dachte, Rutschen dauert mindestens zwei Stunden, habe ich dafür eingeplant. Der Tag ist noch lang. Ich habe jetzt keine Lust mehr auf Rutschen. Aber da habe ich mir auch gedacht, gäbe es irgendeine Möglichkeit, dieser Kassiererin zu sagen, dass sie finde, dass sie einen guten Job macht. Ich glaube, es ist einfach nicht möglich. Lächeln. Ja, okay, klar. Aber ich meine, es würde wahrscheinlich immer als Stalken oder als Flirt oder irgendwas interpretiert werden. Es gibt, also jetzt natürlich gerade bei den zwei Personen. Aber ist es jemand, die das als Flirten, aber ist sie jung? Ist sie noch sehr jung? Ja, schon. Ist sie jemand das Gefühl, da kommen die jungen Wilden jetzt, die mit dem Rutschsystem das Kassierersystem aufwiegeln? Also ich habe mich da selber wiedererkannt in dieser Person, weil ich auch jemand bin, der versucht ... Du willst die Comedy revolutionieren? Nee, das nicht, aber ich versuche, kleine Dinge zu optimieren. Gerade an der Kasse. Halt genau, welche Reihenfolge legst du die Waren auf das Band, wie genau machst du es mit dem Kundendifferenzierungsmodul. Also Ware aufs Band habe ich auch immer die Sachen, die nach unten kommen im Rucksack, immer als erstes natürlich. Ja, aber auch ganz wichtig finde ich, Dinge, die abgewogen werden müssen, nicht als erstes, sondern mittig, damit du während die abgewogen werden schon die erste Hälfte des Einkaufs einpacken kannst. Ja, das musst du warten. Wenn du ganz am Anfang des Bandes die abgewogenen Sachen hast, dann werden die gewogen und du verlierst Zeit, du verlierst wertvolle Zeit. Das Problem an den Gedanken, die du machst, an der Masse der Gedanken, die du da machst, ist, dass du dich über alle Kunden aufregend wirst. Richtig. Das gilt wahrscheinlich, das ist eine gute Metaphe für alles in deinem Leben, du riechst dich wahrscheinlich überproportional viel auf über Leute, weil die meisten machen sich über Dinge in dem Leben nicht so viele Gedanken wie du. Genau, und deswegen war es so toll, da in dem Segment eine Seelenverwandte zu treffen, weil ich mir dachte, die hat sich auch Gedanken gemacht, wie man dieses Problem löst. Aber wie frustrierend das alles sein muss für sie dann, weil sie sagt, oh, jetzt liegen die Grapefruits vorne, ich rasse aus. Ja, ja. Weil das ist ja schon bei mir schon schlimm, wenn ich einmal die Woche einkaufen gehe, ist es ja schon furchtbar zu ertragen, diese Menschen. Ich komme Schweissgeberne immer raus aus dem Rewe. Und das Allerschlimmste ist es, wenn du dir eine Reihenfolge überlegst für deine Waren und du weißt, okay, Glasflaschen ganz nach unten, drüber Tetrapaks, drüber fest so Nudelpackungen oder so und ganz oben dann irgendwie so Chips oder so, die leicht zerbrechlich sind. Und dann hast du die perfekt aufgestaffelt und der Kassierer nimmt aber andere Dinge aus der Reihenfolge. Oh, ich sage, das ist ja gar nicht ihr Kompetenzbereich. Nee, wirklich, wo ich mir ehrlich sage, jetzt pass mal auf, mein Lieber. Ich mache mir hier Gedanken und du greifst mit deinen Patschehänden einfach irgendwo rein, weil oft ist es ja die perfekte Armlänge für die gar nicht so sehr die erste Ware am Band, sondern weiter weg. Und da muss man gucken, und sie hat auch die perfekte Armlänge, dass sie genau die Sachen nimmt, die ich denke, dass sie nehmen wird. Perfekt. Dass ihre Armlänge gemessen? Ich habe nicht ihre Armlänge, ich habe halt mal so meinen Arm daneben gehalten so ein bisschen. Und ich habe mal Tabletop-Spiele gespielt, ich weiß, wie lange mein Unterarm ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es weisst, aber bei Tabletop-Spielen, wenn man so kleine Figürchen auf einem Tisch rumschieben hat, gibt es viele Möglichkeiten zu betrügen. Und manchmal muss man Distanzen abschätzen. Also sind es jetzt 30 Zentimeter oder 40? Und was viele Leute machen, ist, die lehnen sich dann so auf den Spieltisch. Weil sie genau wissen, wie lange ihr Unterarm ist. Wissen genau, wie lange ihr Unterarm ist und können so dann über Umwege herausfinden, wie lang die Distanzen sind. Wow. Ja, kriminelles Mastermind, spielt halt einfach leider Tabletop. Spielt Wymer Fantasy die Nachtelfen. Naja, jedem was die Nachtelfen. Nee, aber das stimmt, da kann man, da ist viel Optimierungspotenzial, ich finde es immer auch toll, solche Leute zu ergeben. Ich habe neulich auch jemanden gelobt. Wir haben ja Zettel bekommen bei der Live-Show, wir haben die Komplimentzettel bekommen. Ja. Wir haben die Komplimentzettel bekommen, vielen, vielen Dank von der Telegram-Gruppe, die dann geschrieben hat, die ja hier genau ausgefüllt hat, können wir auch mal posten irgendwo. Name Komplimentiererin, die Telegram-Gruppe,
Name Komplimentierter,
Stefan und Florentin. Danke für eine
fantastische Live-Show, gerne. Und dann mit
Hintergedanken, keine Hintergedanken, alles drin.
Und sowas bräuchte man vielleicht auch für
Komplimente. Doch, der Hintergedanke
war uns den Kompliment und die Komplimentscheine
zu geben. Ja, und genau
da habe ich mir überlegt.
Es kamen viele Fragen, es macht das nicht unnötig bürokratisch unnötig formell nein das macht es einfach klarer und ich überlege mir ja ob ich nicht einen dieser zettel nehme für die kassiererin und der kassiererin gebe und wir füllen jetzt mal aus komm wir füllen jetzt mal aus schreibe, ich habe eine Kuli für dich, guck mal, so wir können jetzt mal einen Komplimentschein ausfüllen. ausfüllt. Also jetzt hier, also erste Zeit, also erstmal ist Datum, ich lass mal auf. Datum lässt du auf. So, Name komplementiert, komplementieren der. Ja, Florentin. Ja gut. Will. W. Okay, Florentin David Pascal will. Oder Pascal David, ich vergesse es selbst immer. FDP, sagst du immer. David Pascal. Kann man das lesen? Nee, ne? Name Komplimentierte, die Unbekannte. Kassiererin, wissen wir nicht. Im Job als Kassiererin. Okay, Kompliment. Du bist wahnsinnig gut.
Aber du machst einen sehr guten Job. Du machst in Klammern die Rutsche. Sehr gut. Zum Z.B. die Rutsche. Die war schon was gemeint. Du machst einen sehr guten Job an der Kasse. Ja, das ist ein bisschen redundant, weil es ja ihr Job. Naja, gut, nee,
Quatsch, du hast doch mehr, du musst auch die Regale einnehmen.
Ich denke nur an den Platz.
Vor allem,
schau mal das zusammen.
Nee, aber gross. Vor allem
die, und dann, also
die
Rutsche.
Ah, Zwinker.
Nein, nee, nee, dieses Kompliment
ist unironisch und komplett ernst gemeint, ironisch gemeint, eine offene Beleidigung, eine versteckte Beleidigung. Ich sage unironisch und komplett ernst gemeint und hat keine Hintergedanken.
Das ist nämlich clever, weil jetzt will es gar nicht, wobei wiederum, jetzt kann man dem Kompliment scheinen, oh, da ist er wieder, da ist er wieder, kurz Kabel raus, kurz auf dem Kabel gestattet. Warum hat dieses Kabel ein Widerhaken, wenn es bei der ersten Gelegenheit abspringt? Das ist eine gute Frage. Macht mir ein bisschen Sorgen für die Folge. Aber auf der anderen Seite, jetzt kann man diesem krassen Akt des Komplimentscheidens an sich schon vorwerfen, dass er wie ein Hintergedanke aussieht. Ja, also ich glaube, meine Wahrscheinlichkeit als absoluter Psychopath dazustehen, wenn ich diesen Brief hier überreiche, ist recht hoch. Moment, ganz kurz. Stellst du damit gerade in Frage, alle Tipps, die wir jemals gegeben haben, in Frage? Nein, zumal, was ich rausgefunden habe über sie, ich habe nur ein Detail über sie, ich weiß sonst nichts, und zwar weiss ich, dass sie keine Gymnasiasten mag. Das ist das einzige, was ich weiss. Was gut ist, gut zu wissen. Frage. Zwei Fragen. Wann hast du es rausgefunden?
Es war eine spezielle Situation, als ein schüchterner Junge vor mir an der Schlange war, einer dieser unerfahrenen Fließbandkerle, dieser Schwere Nöter.
Ich habe kein Bild in meinem Kopf jetzt. Bei mir ist gerade jemand wie bei Detective Conan, als man den Täter zeigen, aber nicht den Täter zeigen wollte. So eine schwarze Gestalt, die immer gruseliger war als die Auflösung, die habe ich gerade in meinem Kopf. Und dann ist ihm ein Joghurt runtergefallen. Schlecht. Ja, kaputt gegangen. Jetzt die Frage, nachdem er bezahlt hat, bevor er bezahlt hat, während des Bezahlvorgangs. Es hatte schon gepiept, aber noch kein Geld hat die Händchen gewechselt. Du bist ja auf so einer rechtlichen Grenze. Es gab noch keine Rutsche. Wie lustig ist das denn, wenn die Kassiererin etwas kaputt macht, während des Piepens, gehört es dir dann schon? Und alle Jurastudenten, die zuhören, kriegen einen Ausschlag im Gesicht, einfach so einen blutigen Ausschlag. Und jetzt schon die Mail geöffnet. Das ist direkt das Buch aufgeschlagen. Nein, nach dem Bezahlakt wahrscheinlich. Nein, nein, Bezahlakt, einfach Akt an Worten hängen und man lübt einfach sehr. Und Joghurt ist kaputt gegangen und dann wusste er nicht so genau, was er tun soll. Ist ja auch eine blöde Situation, so soll man jetzt selber anfangen, da rumzuwurschteln. Was war es für ein Joghurt? Weisser Joghurt, es war so eine 0,5 Packung, also da war ordentlich Joghurt dahinter. Und er hat seinen Joghurt komplett über den ganzen Boden verschüttet. Also Spritzer links, Spritzer rechts, also der hat die komplette Ladung einfach komplett auf dem Boden geballert und sie guckt halt blöd, denkt sich so, wohin jetzt mit dem Zeug und er fragt sich halt auch, soll ich jetzt selber anfangen? Wenn man zum falschen Moment in diese Story reingesappt hat. Okay. Sie weiß nicht, wohin mit dem Zeug. Genau, und er weiß halt auch nicht, oh Gott, jetzt der ganze Schlons, wo soll der jetzt hin? Wieder rein, soll ich es alles wieder reinschieben?
Oh mein Gott, ja, okay.
Oder soll ich es aufwischen, brauche ich einen Lappen, was mache ich jetzt?
Ja, sage ich dem Bescheid?
Genau, soll ich irgendwas sagen?
Nur Hilfe rufen?
Soll ich jemanden anrufen? Weiss ich nicht.
Und er wusste nicht genau, was er tun soll, und stand so schüchtern da so ein bisschen.
Und dann ...
Sie auch, wusste sie so, was er tun soll?
Ich wusste auch, sie hat ihm, sie hat dann so gesagt, so passt schon im Sinne, so passt schon, wird schon weggemacht irgendwie, ist nicht dein Problem, hau ab jetzt hier. Und dann ist er weggegangen und dann meinte sie so in die Runde so, ah, war bestimmt Gymnasiast. Und dann dachte ich mir, oh okay, sie mag keine Gymnasiasten. Bestimmt Gymnasiast? Ja, halt so im Sinne von, der ist so schlau und der weiß alles, aber ... Booksmart, aber nicht streetsmart. Genau, mit so einer Situation kann er nicht umgehen. Hat er ihn bezahlen müssen? Das weiß ich nicht. Ich war viel zu sehr damit beschäftigt, jetzt darüber nachzudenken, wie ich so ungymnasiastisch wirken kann, wie es nur geht. Und ich dachte, sie darf nie rausfinden, dass ich das Gymnasium Grafing in Niederbayern besucht habe. Wenn das rauskommt, wenn sie mein Abibuch findet, dann war es das. Sehr perfide Angst. Dann ist es vorbei. Ich habe beim Aufräumen auch mein Abibuch wiedergefunden. Ja? Ja, ja. Ich habe Fliegel wiedergefunden generell. Räumt mal auf, Leute, das ist mein Tipp für zu Hause. Nicht wegen des ästhetischen Aspekts, aber auch, aber vor allem, weil man tolle Sachen wiederfindet, über sich selbst auch. Ich habe ja einen Erinnerungsordner. Ordner, aber das ist ein Ordner, ja. Weil alle Erinnerungen müssen ja abheftbar sein dann. Ja, was schon mal eingrenzt. Aber ich bin, glaube ich, sehr gut darin, Erinnerungen zu kuratieren. Erinnerungskisten machen mehr Sinn. Nee. Da passt alles rein. Nee, zu viel Platz. Alles, was nicht auf Diener zwei, auf Diener fünf passt. Ist es nicht wert, sich daran zu erinnern. Erinnern zu werden. Und dann denke ich mir auch so, das Problem an Erinnerungen ist ja oft, dass das die wertvollsten Erinnerungen sind in dem Moment, in dem du sie erlebst, zeigen sich nicht als, oh, daran wirst du dich bald noch erinnern. Du erinnerst dich an Dinge, an völlig unbedenkliche Dinge und denkst dir, da habe ich überhaupt nichts darüber, dieses eine Wochenende in einem Hotel. Und dann denkst du, daran denke ich ständig, aber ich habe nichts darüber, kein Foto nicht, weil ich natürlich im Hotel nicht daran denke, jetzt ein Foto zu machen.
Deswegen, was ich mache, ist, ich hefte manchmal völlig alltägliche Dinge ab, weil ich mir denke, vielleicht könnte das nochmal interessant werden. Okay, okay. Aber auch nicht belanglose Sachen, sondern schon was, wo du denken könntest, vielleicht ist das Spannendste, aber ... Zum Beispiel, wenn ich beim Neo Magazin Royale manchmal so Sachen, so Spielleiter mache, dann kriege ich so Moderationskarten, wo die Antworten und die Lösungen draufstehen. Und so, und bei jedem Mal habe ich diese Karten, werden danach einfach weggeworfen. Aber einmal dachte ich mir, nee, ich hebe eine auf. Aber so einen Tag völlig unbedeutend, ganz normale Sendung wie alle anderen auch, aber ich dachte mir, nee, eigentlich hebe ich eine davon auf, habe eine aufgehoben.
Und jetzt irgendwie in zehn Jahren, wenn das Neo Magazin alles nicht mehr gibt und alles schon vorbei ist und ich endlich Förster bin und mein See buddel, dann kann ich mir irgendwann diese, weil das ist ja eine viel bessere Erinnerung als irgendwie so ein Gruppenfoto nach der letzten Sendung, das ist immer so, weil daran erinnert man sich eh, das ist die letzte Sendung, das ist nichts Besonderes, das ist oft so, naja. Dein Gehirn ist schon auch so im Fotomodus dann. Ja, genau. Du bist im Schnappschussfotomodus. Und wenn ständig betont wird, wie besonders der Moment gerade ist, dann ist er in der Regel nicht besonders. Da erinnert sich niemand dran. Man erinnert sich eher an diese, an die kleinen nebenbei Dinge, wo man dann irgendwie kurz vor dem Auftritt hinter der Bühne stand und es gibt keine Fotos von hinter der Bühne, es gibt tausend Fotos von davor, aber nie mal ein Foto, dass jemand sagt, wie sieht denn das hinter der Bühne aus und deswegen muss man selber machen und diese Erinnerungen einfangen und deswegen hefte ich manchmal so einfach Sachen ab, die schon besonders sind, jetzt nicht irgendwie Kassenzettel vom Einkaufen, aber trotzdem jetzt nichts Ultrabesonnungs, weil ich denke mir so daran kann ich mich später mal. Ich neige auch zu viele Dinge mehr aufzuheben und so. Und jetzt habe ich alle weggeworfen.
Ja, außer die Trompete.
Außer die Trompete.
Aber da wusste ich auch nicht genau, in welchem Müll.
Das hat der Trompete geholfen.
Im Endeffekt, dass ich nicht wusste, in welchem Müll das jetzt kommt.
Da gibt es auch so Sachen, wo man sich einfach denkt,
hast du ein Schwein, dass ich mich nicht mit Recycling auskenne?
Sonst wärst du sowas von weg, Kollege.
Aber viele Sachen, wo man nicht genau wusste.
Du fucking Sandwich-Toaster. Das Kabel hat einen Wackelkontakt, es ist eine riesige Brandgefahr, aber ich habe keinen Plan, wie ich dich entsorgen soll. Also bleibst du. Die genau bezahl... Also es tut mir auch leid, dass ich mich jetzt da oute als jemand, der keine Ahnung hat, aber Restmüll und Kunststoff sind noch zwei verschiedene. Ich habe so eine gelbe Tonne und eine blaue Tonne. Meine Frage, Restmüll, Nomen est Omen? Das ist nicht nur der Titel meiner Autobiografie, sondern auch die Frage, heisst es wirklich den Rest, einfach alles, was den anderen nicht passt? Kann da alles rein? Ja, und wie sauer ist ... nee. Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher. Ich habe eine gelbe Tonne, ich kann zwei Tonnen nicht auseinanderhalten, das macht mich ein bisschen irre. Und deswegen teile ich immer so auf. Ich glaube, das ist nicht falsch. Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht optimal, mein Vorgehen. Trompete hat mit keines von beiden guten Gewissens gepasst. Ja. Und Batterien muss man immer, jetzt wird es auch nur ein Pripräch einfach nur, aber Batterien muss ich einfach, eine Kasse kann ich nicht bringen, da sind dann so diese Batterie-Recycling-Dinger. Oh, da kannst du vielleicht ein bisschen mehr über sie herausfinden, wie sie zu Batterien steht. Ja, ja, ob sie eher so wiederaufladbar oder einweg. Ja, ja, ob Fan von 9-Volt-Akkus diesen Pads ist oder eher von den kleinen A-A's, A-A-A's, kannst du ja immer fragen. Ja, ich will ja eigentlich gar nichts mehr über sie herausfinden. Ich bin völlig zufrieden mit dem, was ich weiß. Du weißt doch genug eigentlich. Ich weiss genug. Ich weiss einfach nur, dass sie verdammt gut in ihrem Job ist. Und wenn sie eines Tages mal nicht mehr da ist, würde ich sagen, die Welt hat eine verdammt gute Kassiererin verloren. Und sie wird vielleicht nicht sterben, aber vielleicht einen anderen Job.
Ey, wenn du stirbst, du bist sowas von auf der Fahndungsliste. Das kann ich dir aber sagen. Ja, okay. Ich glaube sogar, wenn irgendeine Kassierin jetzt auf irgendeine mysteriöse Weise stirbt, bist du oben auf der Fahndungsliste. So viele Informationen, wie du gesammelt hast, gegen ihren Willen. Ich glaube, vor allem dann irgendwann wird man dann sagen, okay, und sie hatte in ihrer Wohnung eine Sache übrig, einen Komplimentschein von Florentin Well, der ihr alles bedeutet hat, der schon seit Jahrzehnten in ihrem Geldbeutel war, mit vielen Knicken, und sie jeden Tag dabei hatte, war es das einzige Mal in ihrem Leben, dass ihr jemals jemand ein Kompliment gemacht hat. Oh mein Gott. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dir mal davon erzählt habe. Wir waren mal in den, während der Schulzeit in den KKK-Tagen. Ja, wir haben alle Gags schon gemacht, keine Sorge. Du musst keine Mühe geben. Du merkst, es brudelt. Ich weiß, es brudelt. Aber wir haben alle Gags schon gemacht. Und da musste man dann halt so Team-Building-Schulen. Wie wo stand KKK? Kommunikation, Kontakt und Ku Klux Klan, das waren die drei. Ich war auf den SS-Tagen, muss man auch sagen, auf den Streitschlichter-Tagen. Und das ist wirklich immer, ach Leute, anderen haben. Ja, wir waren, glaube ich, wir hatten auch die NSDAP-Tage, das war ganz ungünstig, aber manchmal kann man sich Akronyme nicht aussuchen als Ziellehrgang. Wenn HJ da am Ende steht, ist es die HJ. Ach ja, und dann gab es halt so Teambuilding, so Kommunikation, Pubertät, Leute, machen wir einfach irgendwas. Und das weiß ich noch, wie die Lehrerin dann meinte so, ja, jetzt kriegt jeder von euch so einen Diner-Vier-Zettel an den Rücken und dann geht ihr im Raum rum und schreibt auf diesen Zettel auf dem Rücken von Leuten das, was ihr an denen am meisten schätzt. Halt so ein Kram. Hast du den Zettel noch? Und dann meinte sie, und ja, ja, ihr lacht jetzt und lacht mich aus und bewerft mich mit Dreck.
Aber tatsächlich eine kleine Anekdote. Es ist mal im Krieg ein Soldat gefallen. Und dann wurde der geborgen und beerdigt und dann hat man geguckt, was der so bei sich hatte. Und dann hatte der tatsächlich ein solches Diner-Vier-Blatt dabei, wo andere draufgeschrieben haben, was ihnen an ihm gefallen hat. Und ich dachte mir damals schon, jeder Aspekt dieser Geschichte ist Bullshit. Also erstens, als ob irgendwie die Wehrmacht sagt, so Freunde, erster Tag. So Icebreaker, wir spielen Icebreaker. Wir machen mal dieses Spiel, jeder sagt mal seinen Vornamen. Also so ein klassisches Beispiel von Overselling, einfach so, ja, ich check schon, ist es nett, Komplimente zu bekommen, du musst mir nicht eine Geschichte von einem Kriegshelden erzählen, der irgendwie alleine einen französischen Bunker eingenommen hat und dann gestorben ist und dann hat er diesen Zettel bei sich. Ganz merkwürdig. Wo ich mir auch schon dachte, was für ein Krieg war das? Was soll das denn? Lehriger Krieg offensichtlich, wenn die Zeit hatten, diese Kennenlernspiele erst mal zu spielen. Erzählt einfach von uns. Alter Hobby, woher kommt ihr? Und dann so habe ich mir auch gedacht, müssen wir in den Krieg ziehen? Oder so ist das hier. Warum machen wir das? Steht das jetzt? Warum heißt es KKK? Und ich wusste einfach nicht, wohin meine Emotionen in dem Moment. Kinderkommunikation und Kennenlernspiele vielleicht. Kann sein. Und aber auf deine Frage zu antworten, ich habe diesen Zettel noch, weil ich dachte mir, wenn ich jemals in den Krieg ziehe, ich nehme eine eigene Sache bei mir. Das ist keine Knarre, das ist ein Scheiss-Komplimentschein.
Einfach nur, um den Kreis zu schliessen, um diese Geschichte rückwirkend wahrzumachen.
So, nette Idee, meiner Erfahrung nach kann man auf Rücken nicht gut schreiben, also sehr viel unleserliches Zeug dabei.
Dazwischen vielleicht ein paar nette generische Sachen versteckt, wie ich mag deinen Humor.
Ja, vor allem die Komplimente, die darauf kamen, waren eigentlich genau das Gegenteil von Komplimenten, weil eigentlich will man ja keine Komplimente über seine Fähigkeiten haben. Du bist gut in Mathe, du bist gut in Sport, weil ja, no shit, so ist klar, es gibt ein Notensystem, das objektiv bewertet. Wenn ich eine Eins kriege, weiß ich, dass ich gut in Mathe bin, das musst du mir nicht sagen. Du willst ja sagen so, oh, du bist irgendwie ein guter Freund oder ein netter Du bringst mich zum Lachen. Du bringst mich zum Lachen, auf dich kann man sich verlassen. Sowas, das sind irgendwie Komplimente. Und es waren auf diesem Zettel ausschließlich einer hat drauf geschrieben, du kannst gut Bogenschießen. Und obwohl es eigentlich dem widerspricht, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ich bin sehr stolz auf dieses Kompliment. Wenn jemand geschrieben hat, ich bin gut im Bogenschießen. Ich wusste, dass es mein bester Freund war, mit dem ich regelmäßig Bogenschießen gegangen bin. Aber wie geil das Kompliment im Mittelalter gewesen wäre. Ja klar, das sieht das besser. Wow, in der heutigen Zeit nicht mehr so cool. Uncool. All. Aber bei so Mittelalterhelden hätte man das beim besten Held gewesen, wenn man diesen Satz, sie seien gut im Bogen, des Bogens schiessens. Ja, die Fähigkeit mit dem Bogen ist gut. Ja, das wäre halt schön. Das ist ein, wow, ein guter Krieger. Heutzutage, weirdo. Und was war noch drauf? Du kannst gut Mathe. Du hast ...
Nee, das ist aber schon halt so, ja, du bist lustig und hier, aber ansonsten. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hol dich mal raus in nächster Zeit, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, was drauf stand, aber es ist in solchen Situationen natürlich auch keine echten Komplimente, weil du musst halt einfach das Ding füllen und schreibst jedem was drauf und du denkst dir, hier dieses eine Mädchen, das habe ich in meinem Leben noch nie gesehen,ze in der ersten Reihe ganz links, keine Ahnung, dann schreibst du
halt so, ja, du sitzt gut links,
du sitzt von rechts,
siehst du okay aus, links kann ich nicht
bewerten, tschau. Auf deinem Rücken
kann man gut schreiben.
Du hast einen sehr flachen Rücken. Flachen,
festen Rücken.
Ja, sehr aufrechte Körperhaltung,
also allein daran,
dass du das so gut lesen kannst gerade, bemerkst du, du hast einen sehr, sehr geraden Rücken. Falls nicht, ignorier das einfach. Ja, ja. Was für einen Rücken hätte man gerne? Also was ist ein gerader Rücken? Du meinst jetzt unabhängig von dem Spiel, sondern generell. Ja, ich glaube gerade. Breit? Breit, gut, kommt ein bisschen darauf an, was man will. Aber eher oben breit als unten breit.
Als Mann willst du oben breit, unten schmal.
Du willst einen V-Körper haben, natürlich.
Als Frau ist es, glaube ich, ein bisschen diverser.
Also da gibt es ja sicherlich auch Frauen, die generell ein breites Kreuz haben wollen.
Aber das weibliche Ideal,
wenn es das denn geben sollte, ist es
wahrscheinlich auch eher
wenn du sagst Kreuz,
kommt es von Jesus?
Ich glaube doch.
Dass man sagt Kreuz?
Ich glaube man meint damit die Schulterblätter
horizontale
und die Wirbelsäule vertikale.
Habe ich jetzt einfach mal gesagt. Da kann man ja auch T sagen oder so, aber wir müssen auch mal sagen, auch das christliche Kreuz ist kein Kreuz, ist T. Ich bin aus der Kirche ausgetreten. Ja? Ja. Was war es für ein Gefühl? Es war super einfach. Also es wäre super einfach gewesen, wenn ich nicht am falschen Gericht erschienen wäre. Wenn ich nicht... Vom jüngsten Gericht? Vom jüngsten Gericht war ich immer nicht erschienen. Wenn ich nicht auch noch dann vielleicht nur einen Reisepass hatte und nicht meine Meldebescheinigung. Wenn ein paar Dinge gefehlt haben, wäre es nicht gefehlt. Dann wäre es sehr einfach gewesen. War aber auch so sehr einfach. Man muss halt 30 Euro im Austreten zu dürfen. Kriegst du ja nicht zumindest in Köln noch mal so einen skeptischen Blick? Köln ist ja eine sehr katholische Stadt. Ja, ja, also bei der Frau, wo ich bezahlt habe, und das war auch weird. Also, ich finde es ja auch fantastisch. Beim Amt habe ich immer großen Spaß, weil man kann den Amtsbesuch oft nicht, da in dem Fall nicht, aber angenehmer gestalten, wenn du einen Termin vorher machst und so. Und dann kommst du ja, dann ziehst du ja eine Nummer, finde ich schon cool, man zieht nicht häufig Nummern. Orte, an denen du Nummern ziehst, oh, ist geordnet, da hast du irgendwie, ist was Neues, du weißt, jetzt ist was los, da passiert jetzt was. Ich freue mich auch schon, wenn ich für meine neue Wohnung dann mich ummelden muss, muss ich wieder eine Nummer ziehen, freue mich jetzt schon drauf, habe ich mich aufgeregt drauf. Gehst dann halt rein und dann jeder Beamte hat dann so seinen eigenen schönen Arbeitsplatz. Manche haben sich eine Pflanze hingestellt, manche haben sich diese Newton-Kugeln auf den Schreibtisch gestellt, manche haben ein Familienbild und so, manche haben gar nichts. Und du kannst, ich gucke dann immer so gerne rum und freue mich immer, wenn ich bei dem bin, der ein Familienbilder hat und so weiter. Da war das dann so, bei der Frau, bei der man bezahlen muss, bei der Frau, die 30 Euro, wenn man austreten darf, hatte so einen dschungelartigen Raum. Und zwar, aber sie war, man kam in so einen Raum und da war so eine Glasscheibe. Ich glaube, generell alle Bezahlstellen haben das, damit man nicht die beklaut. Eine Glasscheibe, dann konnte man das so unterherschieben. Aber ihr Büro war so grün und die Scheibe war so alt und diese Vorrichtung so ähnlich wie die eines Zoos, wo man halt manche Zoos kann man Tiere füttern. Und dann sah es genau so aus, weil sie das so grün und mit Pflanzen bestückt hat, dass es einfach wie so ein Gehege sah. Und dann habe ich da diesem Tierchen meinen 30 Euro gegeben und dann kam zurück so ein Austrittsschein. Ja, das ist ein grosses Schild, bitte nicht gegen die Scheibe klopfen. Ja. Das war ganz gruselig. Bewillig! Und dann habe ich die ganze Zeit nach so einem Rosenkranz gesucht oder sowas. über dem Bildschirm hängend oder sowas, weil die hat so ein fieses Gesicht gemacht, die hat gar keine Lust darauf, dass ich da austrete, aber das war der einzige skeptische Bild, die ich bekommen habe, wo ich dachte, wenn du aber gläubig bist, dann nimm doch bitte nicht diesen einen Job an, an der Bezahlstelle, und die nimmt nur Bezahlungen für Kirchenaustritte entgegen. Aber kriegt die Kirche auch das Geld? Ja, 30 Euro glaube ich schon, ja. Weil ist es nicht ein bisschen, dass du gerade noch mal um auszutreten die bezahlst? Das ist ja fast wie Erpressung eigentlich, wenn du raus willst, musst du uns bezahlen. Ich finde die Kirchensteuer sowieso echt schwierig, also weil das ja immer einfach abgezogen, auch bei ganz grossen Summen, die du ausgezahlt bekommst, muss du plötzlich einfach anteilig zahlst du an die Kirche. Da wird nicht mal gefragt, das ist einfach immer anteilig. Und so bei regelmäßigen Summen verstehe ich das, bei so grossen Sachen verstehe ich das manchmal nicht, weil da würde ich dir selber gerne entscheiden, was davon an andere Organisationen vielleicht geht oder so. Ich weiß nicht, ich finde das ein bisschen schwierig, dann auch gerade bei so Einmalzahlungen und sowas. Aber deswegen dachte ich, ich würde gerne selber darüber bestimmen, bin ausgetreten, war sehr einfach. Und dann musste man in einen anderen Raum gehen, wo man dann diesen alten Schein, das alte Pergament abgeben konnte. Und dann hat sie ein paar Fragen gefragt, eigentlich nur wo ich geboren bin, wo ich sterben werde und an wen ich jetzt glaube. Und dann konnte man gehen und dann war man entlassen. Eigentlich wäre es konsequent, wenn du so 30 Silbertaler zahlen musst, wenn du aus der Kirche austrittst. Ja. Weil es sind ja auch 30 Euro, oder? Waren es auch 30 Silbertaler? Ja. Ist das Zufall? Ich meine, dass Judas 30 Silbertaler bekommen hat, was damals, also dass es so umgerechnet sind, dass heute 3000 Silbertaler, nur mal um den Kontext zu bewahren. Ja, wie Bitcoins eigentlich. Eigentlich wie Bitcoin, ja. Was hat er damit gemacht eigentlich? Das steht nicht in der Bibel, das sind so Sachen. Ja, man braucht dieses, was man manchmal so bei Rom-Coms hat, dieses Judas hat jetzt einen Kreppstand in der Lombardei, sowas, das würde ich gerne wissen. Ja genau, oder halt sein Shopping-Spree. Einfach so dann, gib mir alle Sandalen, die du hast. Einfach macht er sich einen richtig schönen Tag. Aber am Ende ist er leer. Aber es ist dann auch wie so bei Bart, der seine Seele verkauft, dass du dann, nur weil du diesen Zettel überreicht hast, dich dann leerer gefühlt hast? Ja. Ich fühle mich ein bisschen leerer jetzt, aber auch reicher. Ich glaube ja eh, dass bei dir noch so eine spirituelle Phase kommt. Wir haben ja auch letztens darüber geredet, was es noch so für Stefans gibt, weil ich sehe bei dir immer so wie so eine Cornflakes-Packung, wo halt du immer so, also Benjamin Blümchen mässig, so Benjamin Blümchen im Zoo und dann nächstes Jahr Benjamin Blümchen als Astronaut. Ich sehe mich wirklich, auch jeden Urlaub, den ich habe, oder jeden Ausflug, sehe ich immer, eigentlich sehe ich mich immer wie so eine Comicfigur, das schon recht, oder wie Peter Griffin, weil sobald Peter Griffin in Mexiko ist, trägt der sofort ein Sembrero, dem wächst sofort ein Schnurrbart und er spricht fließend Spanisch. Und genau so sehe ich mich auch immer in Ländern. Da war ich Stefan in Rom neulich, am Anfang des Jahres war ich ein paar Tage in Rom. Ich habe direkt Italienisch gesprochen, fliessend, so ein kleiner Vespa-Roller irgendwie. Na tschau, Ben, hallo! Direkt drei Dezibel lauter gesprochen. Und ich glaube, da ist nur die Frage so, ich glaube auch, dass die Benjamin Blümchenautoren irgendwie nach Staffel sechs oder so echt Schwierigkeiten hatte und einfach irgendwie so die Berufsliste durchgegangen sind und so, was kann er sein, Maurer, Maurer, Schau. Oder so Asterix bei den Römern. Ja, genau. So ein bisschen das, genau. Bei den Römern, ach ja, okay, das haben wir jetzt, Römer, so was noch. Ja, genau, aber bald kommt Stefan und der Buddha. Ja, genau. Ich glaube, eh, dass die nächste Staffel Stefan experimenteller wird. Wir hatten jetzt viele naheliegende Sachen irgendwie, ja, Moment, wirfst du gerade in den letzten drei Teilen eine gewisse generische Art vor? Nee, da musst du ja durch, so, das macht ja alle, macht ja jeder irgendwie. Da machst du mal eine Zeitreise, genau, machst du eine Zeitreisefolge, dann machst du mal eine Folge, die in einem abgeschlossenen Raum ist, eine Folge nur im Flugzeug, hu hu hu, kreativ, so. Und dann hast du auch hinter dir. Sorry. Und dann wird es experimentell. Und dann, glaube ich, kommt Stefan noch mal spirituell irgendwie. Dieses Jahr kommt auf jeden Fall Stefan zieht um, ist auch noch naheliegend. Danach kommt aber auch Stefan in Japan, kommt dieses Jahr auch noch. Ja. Und das ist schon spannend, weil danach kann, glaube ich, Zen-Stefan. Ja, kann auch sein. Kann ich mir, ja, ich weiß nicht, wie Zen-Stefan aussehen will, aber ich glaube, du würdest lang boring, boring as fuck. auch wirklich dann so auf die Glatze geschoren haben und dann so wirklich Schaolin-mässig dann auch Kampfsport machen und sowas in der Richtung. Vielleicht, ja, ja. Aber ich glaube, du fällst auch nochmal richtig tief in eine Sekte rein, sorry, aber ich glaube, so richtig tief in eine Sekte, so dass du richtig erst mal so ein Erweckungserlebnis wieder brauchst und du so langsam abdriftest. Am Anfang erzählst du ja, ich war da bei so einem Treffen und irgendwie so nach dreimal hast du dann irgendwie so eine Narbe und dann wurde dir irgendwas eingesetzt oder so, eingepflanzt, so ein Chip und irgendwie da driftest du mehr ab. Du, ich sag nur, aus der schlimmsten Sekte bin ich ja gerade wahrscheinlich rausgetreten. Wow! Leider bei der Pointe versprochen, aber you get the idea. Nicht schlecht.
Ich glaub auch.
Und er hat eine schöne Kirche ausgetreten, dreissig Silbertaler in der Hand auf seinem Busselbohren, zack, verlässt er den ins Amt. Und dann war ich beim Trichterbrustarzt. Also nur um mir sagen zu lassen, wie es so aussieht in meiner Gesundheit. Ich war lange nicht mehr beim Trichterbrustarzt. Die heißen auch nicht so, ich weiß das wohl. Ich musste nämlich in die Kinderchirurgie. Ich war im Trichterbrustzentrum in Düsseldorf. Aber es ist nicht so, jeder, dem man da entgegenkommt, man nickt sich so wissend zu. Ja, und der Arzt wusste es auch und macht auch Gags darüber, weil ich bin dann zur Trichterbrust-Sprechstunde, es gibt auch kein deutscheres Wort als Trichterbrust-Sprechstunde, ja, und man kennt das ja, manchmal googelt man so Sachen, die man hat, so mal Lessen, und dann gibt es dafür ein Zentrum. Und das Trichterbrustzentrum war in Düsseldorf. Wie gross ist die Chance? Es ist ja um die Ecke, ich bin da eine halbe Stunde hingefahren. Vor mir, ich habe ewig da gewartet im Wartezimmer, im Trichterbrust Wartezimmer, und zwar, weil der vor mir da war, auch ein Jugendlicher, kam aus der Schweiz extra dahin. Ärgerlich. Wenn der googelt, Trichterbrustzentrum, Düsseldorf, na, schade. Der hat eine weite Anreise, muss er auch ein Hotel wahrscheinlich dafür haben.
Aber haben die, als sie diese Klinik geöffnet haben, haben die geguckt, wo es die meisten Trichterbrustpatienten gibt und haben gesagt, jetzt müssen wir auch da eröffnen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Eine Auswertung?
Und dann musste ich in die Kinderklinik, in die Kinderchirurgie, weil es ist komisch, weil es tritt schon ab der Geburt auf und wird bei den meisten im Kindesalter behandelt. Also hat sich die Kinderchirurgie darauf fokussiert, also musste ich mich in der Kinderchirurgie anmelden. Und das Tolle ist, dass diese Menschen da nur gewohnt sind, mit Kindern zu reden. und alles an denen, diese Formulare mit Giraffenstickern und so, alles daran habe ich behandelt wie ein Zwölfjährigen. Konstant geduzt auch. Und dann wurde ich auch die ganze geduzt, war toll, fand ich das. Und dann habe ich auch ewig gewartet, weil jemand aus der Schweiz davor war und dann kam auch diese Frau zu mir, ach wartest du immer noch hier? Aber der vor dir, der hatte eine ganz weite Anreise aus der Schweiz und ich sag's da, ja, ja, ja, ich kenne die Schweiz. Aber du hast ja schon schön was gemalt, oder? Ja. Was soll ist das denn? Giraffe. Einige, die ist ja richtig schön, richtig langer Hals. Hat sieben Halswirbel. Ja, toll. Laberdummer. Ja, ja, seltsam mit deiner Brust. Aber hast du einen auch Lutscher bekommen oder so? Lutscher bekommen, Eis bekommen, alles bekommen. Dann, äh. Im Lutscher ist ja das Eigentliche drin, ne? Was dich gefügig macht. Ja, genau. Die Behandlung selber macht nichts, aber der Lutscher ist es. Du kriegst auch keine Medikamente, der Lutscher ist es, was dich am Ende heilt. Jedenfalls hat er mir gesagt, und ich stehe ja auch nach wie vor dazu, wir, Trichterbrbrüder da draußen und Schwestern, es gibt nicht so viele Schwestern, mehr Brüder, wir lassen uns nicht operieren, wir stehen dazu. Unsere stolz eingefallene, stolze Brust recken wir den Himmel. Wie heißt nochmal der Promi, der eine Ritterbrust hat? Brandon Fraser. Brandon Fraser. Brandon Fraser. Und ja, ich weiß, ihr da draußen, wir wünschen uns alle, dass Brandon Fraser ein bisschen erfolgreicher wäre. Er hat es nicht zum Testimonial gesagt. Wir schaut uns jeden seiner Filme an, egal wie schlecht. Und ich sage euch, der hat eine Grütze gemacht. Oh mein Gott, ich fang gar nicht erst mit dem Vermächtnis des Tempers, diesem ganzen Quatsch, diesem Diane Krüger Bullshit. Auch in der Trichterklinik einfach an jeder Ecke flimmert irgendwie, das Vermächtnis der Tempers. Große Poster von Brandon Fraser, auch so wie man das kennt aus so Pizzerien, wo Leute Promis da waren. Brandon Fraser war natürlich auch da. Schüttel so einen die Hand, ja. Einen die Hand, aber auch Jeff Goldblum hat eine kleine Trichterbrust. Ah, okay, das wird aber ungern gesehen, oder? Ungern gesehen. Eine kleine? Der ist nicht so richtig Teil des Teams. Nee, man schaut sich auch neidisch auf seinen Oberkörper. Ja. Gibt es auch dieses Bild, das berühmte Bild, wo er bei Jurassic Park so auf dem Tresenlungert, da hat er auch eine Trichterbrust. Na ja gut, und ich habe ja gesagt, wir sind stolz darauf, wir lassen nichts machen. Ich bin ganz ehrlich, ich bin nicht so,
ich bin kein guter
Vertreter, kein Spokesperson,
weil hätte der
mir gesagt, ja, wir machen eine kleine Operation,
sieht das blendend aus bei Ihnen, wäre ich
der Erste, der gesagt hätte, ja, muss ich unterschreiben.
Aber es ist nicht so.
Und zwar
ist es immer ein grosser Eingriff
und so, und ich ermüchte
da meistens meine Rippen, die so ein bisschen
hervorstechen, da müssten grosse Schnitte gemacht werden,
da müssten die Rippen abgeschnitten werden, die wachsen dann
normal wieder nach, es sind auch nur Knorpel.
What? Rippen wachsen nach?
Die Knorpel vorne, das sind die,
um die es geht, die würden wieder nachwachsen,
normal und so, hätte aber zwei
im schlimmsten, man weiß nicht genau, wie es läuft, im schlimmsten Fall wächst es genauso wieder nach oder noch schlimmer, und ich hätte zwei Narben, also noch schlimmer, man weiss nicht, wie es endet, das ist alles so risikoreich, habe ich auch gedacht, coole Narben, sind es coole Narben oder unkwürde Narben, und ja, es sind halt nicht, es sind halt nicht, ich bin in einer Gangstecherei gewesen, sondern es sind halt Schönheits-OP-Narben. Naja, aber offensichtlich, weil die so schön symmetrisch
sind. Von daher, lass ich das
alles nicht machen, das ist alles Quatsch. Ich lebe es damit
und bin auch stolz darauf. Finde ich gut.
Mir ging es nur darum, herauszufinden,
inwieweit es mich gesundheitlich einschränkt
und was ich denn sportlich dagegen machen kann.
Und er hat herausgefunden, es drückt ein bisschen auf mein Herz.
Und er hat sich gewundert,
warum ich mich so gefreut habe bei dieser Nachricht,
weil es die beste Ausrede ist, warum ich nicht jogge. Das ist die beste Ausrede aller Zeiten, warum ich keinen Cardio-Scheiss mache. Meine Trichterbrust drückt leicht aufs Herz. Na also. Perfekt. Du, sag mal ganz kurz, wir würden am Samstag haben wir Umzug und da brauchen wir noch ein paar Leute. Oh, ich würde so gerne helfen, aber meine Trichterbrust drückt leicht aufs Herz. Leicht aufs Herz. Ja, dann kannst du ja ein paar die leichteren Kisten tragen. Nein, Art hat gesagt nicht, dass der Umzug auf gar keinen Fall beim Umzug helfen. Tschau, hier ist mein Attest. Tschau, fuck you, fuck you. Was ist mit dir, Brandon? Ja, bin auch raus. Aber es ist ja immer so die Frage, was war zuerst da, die Trichter Klinik oder die Trichter Brust Leute?
Also ist dann, wo die Klinik ist, gibt's
dann auch gehäuft, Trichter Brüste außen
oder was sagt man denn, Trichter Brüste?
Nee, die siedeln sich da gerne an, weil die
sich da in guten Händen wissen. Ja, ich war ja
mal in der WG mit,
und du lernst ja in der WG die Leute erst so langsam
kennen, wenn du die gar nicht kennenlässt und so, und dann
fällt ab und zu, und man denkt sich ja so,
ich glaube, man kann mit jedem Menschen zehn Minuten
reden und man findet die okay, weil da kommen keine
Vielen Dank. Und du lernst ja in der VG die Leute erst so langsam kennen, wenn du die gar nicht kennst und so. Und dann fällt ab und zu, und man denkt sich ja so, ich glaube, man kann mit jedem Menschen zehn Minuten reden und man findet die okay. So, weil da kommen keine Sätze, wo man jetzt groß was dagegen hat. So, dann erzählt man sich halt, was man so beruflich macht und ja. Aber irgendwann kommt dann immer so die Zeit, wo dann so der erste Satz fällt, wo man sich denkt, okay. Ich war übrigens acht Jahre im Gefängnis. Ach, wow, ja. Und aus, ich, ohne Kontext hat dann diese Person gesagt, ja, also die Person hat auch ganz viele so Kräuter und Heilkräuter und sowas und Tees und so und ja, von mir aus. Und dann so, ja, ich gehe fest davon aus, dass dort, wo bestimmte Krankheiten auftreten, an denselben Orten auch die Kräuter wachsen, die diese Krankheiten heilen. Und das war so... Mega spannender Gedanke für so einen Endzeit-Thriller. Auf dem ersten Gedanken denkt man sich, ja, warum? Also was? Es ist so, vor allem die Aussage ist... Es ist kein Conversation Starter. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Und die Aussage ist auch nicht so absurd, dass ich jetzt dagegen argumentiere. Ich denk mir nur so, es ist so eine, alles bricht, es bricht ohrbetäubendes Schweigen aus. Es ist so, es geht von, oh, Gespräch, Gespräch, Gespräch zu, wer sagt das nächste Wort? Denken, denken, denken zu, oh shit, ich sollte schnell wieder was sagen. Aber das ist auch so, und vor allem das war auch nicht, und dann auch so, aha, okay, und wie, dann so, und wie ist der Mechanismus, wie sieht der Mechanismus dahinter aus, warum ist das so? Auch nur so, nee, ich glaube einfach, dass es so ist. Ach so. Und das war so, du hast einen ganz spezifischen Glaubenssatz, aber ohne dass du, also wenn ihr sagt, ich habe das mal erlebt oder mir hat das mal jemand gesagt oder aus den und jenen Gründen, weil Gott will, dass die Menschen geheilt sind, deswegen pflanzt er da die Pflanzen, an die die heilen, okay, dann kann ich ja bezahlen. Aber im Umkehrschluss heißt das doch, wenn er bei sich dann im Zimmer oder sie diese ganzen Kräuter hatte, will, wenn er angenommen, er kommt in dein Zimmer und stellt dir so eine Heilpflanze auf, will er dann, dass du diese Krankheit bekommst, gegen diese Pflanze, im Umkehrschluss. Und es war dann auch so, ah okay, und all diese Pflanzen, die du hast, die hast du dann aus der direkten Umgebung, oder? Das heißt, hier tritt es überall auf. Du kannst ja keine Krankheiten kriegen, die irgendwie dann fernöstliche Sachen, oder? Und dein Kurkuma-Tee, der kommt auch hier direkt auf dem Spielplatz her gewachsen oder was.
Also es war ganz komisch.
Es war aber auch, das ist auch so ein Satz, der so, wo man nicht dagegen argumentiert, wo es auch egal ist, aber einfach so, man hat so einen Einblick in eine fremde Welt und sich denkt, okay. Ja, aber auch so Coronavirus, da habe ich mir auch viele Fragen jetzt gestellt, erst mal wie absurd überrepräsentiert dieses Thema ist in den Medien.
Ist es tödlich oder nicht?
Relativ, nur für sehr kranke Menschen wird er immer wieder betont.
Und da dachte ich mir aber auch, es tritt ja auf in so dicht bevölkerten Gegenden, dicht bevölkerten Gegenden in China, wo man auch sagt, war das dem Planeten, man sagt ja auch immer, will der Planet sich reinigen. Ja, dem ist es zu eng geworden. Der Planet will sich mal so schütteln, wie so ein Hund, der nass geworden ist. Er kratzt sich mal so hinterm Ohr. Lässt dann so eine Krankheit ausbrechen, die die Schwächsten umbringt, die eh schon angezählt waren. Da kommen mir auch schon so Gedanken, das ist alles Quatsch und nicht annähernd belegt oder empirisch begründet. Aber da kommen mir auch solche weirden Gedanken wie der ehemalige Mitbewohner, weil man auch kurz denkt, warum in der Gegend oder einfach, weil es sehr nicht bevölkert ist und es da eh viele kranke Menschen gab und so und es sich leicht verbreiten konnte.
Vor allem ist nicht irgendwie SARS oder so auch aus Fledermäusen entstanden? Sind es nicht am Ende? Ich will jetzt hier keine Hetze betreiben oder so, gar nicht. Sind sie am Ende immer die Fledermäuse? Aber auch Ebola kam alles von Fledermäusen. Aids kam von Affen. Ja, aber woher hatten es die? Fledermäuse. Voll Fledermäusen. Man einfach sagt, war das vielleicht einfach eine dumme Idee, die einfach anleben zu lassen, einfach die mal zu streicheln zu wollen, weil die sind süss, aber tückisch.
Und können fliegen.
Verdammt tückisch.
Beinrugten Tiere sind das.
Ich meine, die schlafen falschrum.
War das nicht der Punkt? Das sind die einzigen Säugetiere, die fliegen?
Ne, Delfine. Fliegen bis Wasser. Sind Flughunde und Fliedermäuse, die einzigen Säugetiere, die fliegen. Vielleicht weiss es nicht. Ich auch nicht. Stefan, ich weiss es nicht. Aber das wird auch weird. Wenn alle Krankheiten auf das eine Tier
zurückzuführen sind, was
nicht fliegen sollte, aber fliegen kann.
Und dann
Vampire sind ja
auch von Fliedermäusen, also
sind ja wie übernatürliche Tiere auch so ein bisschen.
Ja. So auch in der Mythologie.
Und Vampire sind ja auch ein Virus, die breiten sich ja auch
aus. Und die können nicht sterben.
Lass uns mal darüber nachdenken. Da liegt was, aber es ist ähnlich wie bei den Mitbewohnern, nicht annähernd ausgereift. Nee, überhaupt nicht ausgereift. Vor allem, was mich dann bei solchen Viren-Epidemien stört, ist dann das Konzept des Mundschutz. Dass dann Leute mit dem Mundschutz rumlaufen, wo man sich einfach sagt, okay, der Virus kann Kilometer zurücklegen und irgendwie Horden von Menschen infizieren in kürzester Zeit, es gibt kein Heilmittel, aber an so einem fucking Mundschutz kommt der nicht vorbei, da kommt der nicht durch. Da kommt der nicht durch. Ich denke mir auch immer so, ist das kommt der, ist das wirklich so, kommt der da wirklich nicht durch, weil da kommt ja Luft durch, sonst würde man ja ersticken. Aber der überdreht sich ja über Tröpfchen. Und die kommen da nicht durch? Nee. Die kommen da wirklich nicht durch, Stefan? Nicht wenn die da so schnell rankommen? Nein, die mögen das nicht. Ich glaube, dem Virus sehen Leute mit Mundschutz zu krank aus. Und deswegen wollen die damit nichts zu tun haben. Aber ich glaube, man könnte eigentlich den Leuten alles erzählen. Ich glaube, auch wenn du jetzt gerade so einen Virusausbruch hast, und dann fängst du an, mit so Ohrenschonern rumzulaufen. Ja, ja. Und dann alle so, oh fuck, fuck, fuck, brauchen wir Ohrenschonern. Alle kaufen Ohrenschoner. Du verkaufst die Ohrenschoner. Haben wir auch den Virus gesät? Nee, du wartest nur, bis ein Virus ausbricht und läufst dann irgendwie mit so einem Fahrradhelm rum oder mit so Fingerhüten. Du ziehst dir dann die Fingerhüte an und alle denken sich, oh shit, jetzt müssen wir alle die Fingerhüte tragen. Oh shit, was ein Freak. Ja, entweder oder, oh fuck, ich brauche auch Fingerhüte, schnell. Aktienkurs in die Höhe. Stefan, hier oben muss man es haben, nicht nur in den Fingern. Niemand sieht, wo du hintippst. Hier muss man, nicht nur hier, sondern auch hier muss man es haben. Es werden Leute nicht wissen, dass sie nicht zu sehen sind. Podcasts sind die Zukunft, sind einfach die Zukunft. Was haben wir noch vor? Wir haben jetzt die 200 gerissen. Was sind unsere grossen Ziele für den Podcast? Was haben wir noch vor? Folge 300? Folge 400? Wo ich mich richtig drauf freue, ist Folge 500. Oh ja. Das wäre auf jeden Fall noch ein Punkt. Also, aber dann ist auch mal irgendwann gut. Dann ist es irgendwann gut? 200, es fühlt sich mehr oder weniger an. Es fühlt sich bei mir fast genau wie 400 an. Mein Gefühl ist identisch mit der Realität. Tatsächlich. Ne, es fühlt sich weniger an irgendwie. Als wir gemacht haben? Ja. Weniger als wir gemacht haben. Es fühlt sich an wie so 187. Aber ich bin noch nicht bei 200 ganz wir haben ja zwei Folgen gelöscht, also eigentlich ist es schon 202 so fühlt sich das noch nicht an so, dies ist eine schöne Woche ganz ganz liebe Grüße nochmal an Tobias für dieses fantastische Intro das jetzt nochmal kommt und wir wünschen euch ganz viel Spaß mit weiteren 100 Podcast-Upo-Folgen.
Ja.
Vielen Dank, Stefan.
Vielen Dank, Florentin Will.
Macht's gut, haut rein, schöne Woche, macht's gut. Und wir heben.
Ciao. Rentin, sie sind das fröhliche Toboteam, stets auf der Suche nach dem Sinn,
nun lauscht im Zauber der Spaßbeginn, sie schreiben Träume, Geschichten, Wunderbunt, raffiniert und durchdacht, jedes Wort ein Königswerk. Seid ihr traurig oder einsam? Hört nur hin wie sie grazil, Worte sanft in Gold verwandten. Das sind Florentin und Stefan, Florentin und Stefan, Florentin und Stefan, Florentin und Stefan, Florentin und Stefan, Flore Team, Stefan und Martin.
Es ist super Zeit, wir werden hören und lauschen, wie beide sanft blauschen.